could you speak to this difference what
is the difference and similarities
between judaism christianity and islam
um the religious family part is
different and the the greatest
difference which i talked about in the
eric weinstein podcast is that
islam and judaism are more similar in a
lot of ways than judaism and
christianity
and the reason that that is so is
christianity in its core is not a
religion of law
the reason it's not a religion of law is
because it grew up in the roman empire
so law was taken care of i mean jesus
didn't have to create civil law because
you had roman law
muhammad and moses created a religion in
the desert where there was no law
so you have to create a religion of law
otherwise
you have anarchy
and that's why in a lot of ways like
there was never a separation of church
and state in islam or judaism that was a
gift that christianity gave the world
and it could do it because of render
unto caesar what is caesar's but when
moses came along there was no caesar
when muhammad came along there was no
caesar so historically
the traditions shaped differently
but all three of them
have this core
i think the single most
important
statement and insight in all of human
history which is that every human being
is in the image of god
and if you believe if you really believe
that that's a transformative
belief
so that means
you should love
you know thy neighbor as thyself which
comes from leviticus comes straight from
the torah
so
uh i don't know if if you know i've been
chatting with omar sullivan i don't know
if you know who that is he's an imam in
dallas uh great guy i enjoy
his interfaith dialogues that he engages
in
and uh do you ever do that kind of talk
with christians with muslims yes often
often i'm i mean i do whenever i at
least listen to them
in the context of these kinds of
conversations there's so much love and
humor
and um
empathy and appreciation and also
ability to make fun of the quirks
of the
little of one's own on one's own
communities you know like so it's not
you know necessarily the depths of the
details of the traditions but you know
these are communities and they're full
of people and they're full of
weird people because we're all weird and
so you there is
very particular
flavors of weirdness that emerge and
they can make fun of them um and then in
that way they can talk about some like
beautiful ideas so i mean i don't know
do you engage in these kinds of things
what would you learn from them um so one
of the things i learned is exactly what
you said that personalities that you
think are unique to your own community
in fact they exist in all sorts of
communities and religious communities in
particular draw i think some interesting
personalities um and also that the
especially as clergy some of the
pressures that you feel
are shared
um
and
and it's weird again it has to do with
that tribal association there's almost
like there's an understanding among
clergy because they have similar
stray and
it's a strange role in the following way
it's one that you never escape
that is
you're not you're you're not my lawyer
at the supermarket but you are my rabbi
at the supermarket i mean it doesn't
matter
why you're there
that's not an escapable role and every
religious leader is aware of that
um
that strange assumption of
of stepping into something that you can
never step out of but you're also
the source where people go to
to think about the deepest question of
our lives and our our universe and so
that's some heavy you know when people
are suffering
they look to you for answers
i mean every privilege comes with a cost
of one kind or another the reason you
get to be in that role is exactly
because you get the privilege of being
there at crucial moments in people's
lives i mean the fact that i get to
marry people and get to
give eulogies for people and
come to the hospital at that's
it's inexpressible i have this joke with
uh people that i know that like when i'm
sitting on the couch and it's saturday
night i don't want to get up and go to a
wedding i really don't i want to sit
there and watch netflix like everybody
else
but when i'm actually doing the wedding
i'm i always love it always always
always um
and
and the reason is that i don't think i
mean yes people go to you for answers in
in calmer conversations like if you ask
me now like what's my theory of why god
allows evil i could give you a
conversation about it
but they really go for presence and
comfort not really for answers when
someone's suffering an answer doesn't
doesn't make them unsuffer
you know it's just they want to know
they're not alone yeah to be heard and
just to feel things in silence together
you